[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host on shotgun very
excited about talking about being an
international student from China we have
session Wong aka Alisha joining us on
the show hello hello thanks so much for
coming
we're very excited you are also a
freshman at minerva schools and we are
very grateful for minerva schools
ecosystem so many international students
getting to collab together we've had you
know sydney now on the show and azar on
the show now you this is very exciting
I'd like love these 19 year old minds
that are that are that are just cutting
edge of young people I love it for those
that don't know Alicia's background
she is from Shanghai in China she's an
international student very focused on
art and science at the Minerva schools
and freshmen 19 so let's start things
off check out links in the bio for those
that want to check out malicious
profiles so or set gens profiles I'm
doing got to get into the culture of
foreign languages and names this is so
important so let's start off soften this
big history perspective so we find
ourselves as stewards of earth we're
running in the human experiment what is
your take on the state of humanity oh I
have to say I don't know everything
nobody knows everything that's why I can
only say from my own perspective which
probably is pretty narrow but I do think
we are at the brink of something just
because there are lots of things going
on in the world right now for example we
got the first genetically edited twins
in China and I think from the in terms
of evolution we don't know what is the
long-term effect of that and we also
have like human activities interacting
with the social
with the earth with environment for
example when let's take weather as an
example the weather prediction forecast
might not be that accurate right now
just because we as human beings are also
affecting the whole ecosystem and then
the ecosystem is now like sort of
reacting back and that that like complex
system perspective which I think well
like will change a lot within like five
or ten years yeah yeah as an aspiring
scientists and an artist that you you
immediately jump to the genetic
engineering and the way that kind of we
call them throughout the scene the
period of time where humans are causing
the most interaction with the climate
and change in the climate and so and
controls the dominant species on earth
of course it's great that you you know
that you jump there and also it it it
speaks of you know you're you you you're
looking at things to the edge like you
care a lot about what's happening at the
edge of the science and so you know
maybe tell us quick you know why do you
care so much about going to the edge
going to the edge I think it is
basically for everything I do I learned
I study it is because of curiosity that
I want to know the world better I want I
want at least try to understand how the
functions and also to for example
predict trying to predict the complexity
of the whole system and that is why I
put a lot of attention towards what is
going on within the field of science and
also in terms of like the longer
evolution of human and I think it is
interesting do you think in terms of
like a very broad way and yeah I really
want I really want to see how things is
going in the world right
yeah you've mentioned uh multiple times
this complex systems understanding that
even a tiny bit of like extraction of
some resource in a place in the world
has a massive impact on the ecosystem in
that place and migration patterns
animals living there there's all
different types of stuff that actually
gets affected by this including the
people that get to consume the resources
wherever it gets delivered to so that's
a very very good lens I'm glad that you
brought that up so and you brought up
curiosity which is a good segue because
this is kind of like what you have told
Tommy is that that has been your kind of
your main pillar and driver of your life
growing up and and and picking what
you're most interested in and it's more
its oh this is different this is I would
say probably quite different being in
Shanghai in China then like I was in
Sioux Falls in the middle of the United
States of South Dakota Iran was on the
East Coast near Boston in puberty and
this is a you know like what is it like
in Shanghai for me like I am pretty
lucky that my family is sort of allowing
me to discover everything around me and
they don't constrain me on like which
you should do in the future so that is
why when I show my interest for the
nature when I was like very little and I
was like three or four years old my mom
was very supportive and she brought me
all the books that I want and also for
every weekend my family will bring me to
like picnic bring me to a museum to a
Science Museum and it to like sort of
experience what is not only what is
happening in the world but also like
what it's like explain to me how the
world works in terms of science so that
is how I become very very interested in
this field and growing up as
international students in Shanghai I am
I am really lucky because like I have
the opportunity to pursue what I am what
I am interests
I'm so around 7th or 8th grade I become
very very interested in biology in terms
of like the whole science field and my
teachers was very supportive we found
like anatomy class and then we did read
science journals and more like published
some of them within our school journals
so yeah that was like you were an editor
yeah yeah I was and I was her and yeah I
also published some you know at like
school journals so it was I was very
lucky because everything around me
basically supports me and allows me to
pursue what I am interested in that's
huge so MA so mom and dad were big
supporters of getting you the books that
you wanted to like they weren't very
constricted on what path you could take
they were letting you play and figure
out what you wanted to do so that's huge
and then also kind of taking on you know
with your interesting curiosity you took
on leadership roles which is very
important what would you say then was
kind of like that experience of growing
up did you have you had you know your
your sister came much later like when
you're 14 she was she was born so it's
much later but that you know growing up
in that culture in that economics and
that political and social sphere what
what is that like teach us about that
for me I didn't quite access the
difference between me and like other
families who has more children however I
do think with more children that will
cultivate more responsibility within the
the bigger ones and also for the only
child as my family people like because
we have this system in China which like
her family only can have one child child
and it is only until 2014 that the
policy goes open and say like you can
have two child yeah I have excellent so
growing up in the environment that
people around me are all single child in
their family it is sort of a lot
different from like when I came to
Minerva because sometimes people are not
that caring
because they are not used to for example
like caring for others caring for a
little or younger brothers or sisters
and but look at the other hand they got
all the resources within the family so
that they probably have like more can I
see freedom or like they have more
opportunity to do what they want because
all the their parents attention are like
completely on there so yeah and then
then that first of all is the crazy
thing is living somewhere where where
the government says that you can only
have one child that's a very very crazy
thing but at the same time yet
population is a very important thing
also take into account and everything
but then growing up now you know you
were teaching me about this there's
about seventeen thousand or so Mandarin
characters but you only you know need to
know if you apply it you know predator
should be seen Oh probably only twenty
percent of those characters are gonna be
used eighty percent of the time so maybe
somewhere around like three thousand or
so are use the majority of the time and
this is like a rote memorization thing
you see a character you have to remember
that it's you man or woman or dog or
pizza or whatever yeah yes so yeah
teaches about what's like as you said
you know you start doing this because
this is like a whole new way when you're
learning English and Mandarin at the
same time growing up you know you're
learning the English words what they
mean the men are in characters what they
mean this is a very interesting to me I
think they are two completely different
language system for mentoring we are
sort of using our picture memory to sort
of like memorize how a character looks
like and then to associate it with a
certain meaning and by combining like
for example a and B and then we garlic a
V which is a brand new different meaning
from a and B so like doing that like
combining words and like sort of play
around with characters it is like it is
much different like difficult to English
just because English has like like only
like a certain amount of
it and then although some of the
vocabularies are very close very
different we still can like for example
read a word even though we don't know
what is mean but like in Chinese is
impossible like if you don't know that
character you cannot read it you might
have you might kind of guess it but like
it is not for certain that it will
pronounced that way so I can sound out a
word in English you can like sound it's
like a brand new picture that you do
yeah so but I do think lots of Chinese
are nowadays learning English and then
the society are valuing the like the
skills of English very much so
yeah more people are starting to get
international and then to to like voice
their ideas why I mean Shanghai's what
20 million people just itself it's a big
24 million yeah we four million people
just itself which is double the brain
area it's like that's nuts
and so then is it you know when you're
when you're growing up it's it's pretty
like that the families in Shanghai are
doing fairly well because it's
considered like a Tier one city so that
you have to have you have to be of a
certain economic status to be able to
afford to even like live there and stuff
right yeah yeah mostly right yeah but
there are some occasions that people
come to work in Shanghai that's like
they find more opportunities here and
people like come to Shanghai to study
University here so yeah there are a lots
of locations that people are not in
Shanghai that they can can
common than to learn and live here yeah
and when you know nazar is just on the
last episode he was teaching us that you
taught him yes yes yes because this is
this is cool stuff is that China in many
ways has a has kind of leapfrog a little
bit in terms of tech and they kind of
kind of figured out that if you can
incorporate you know if everyone's using
WeChat and this is a ten-cent company if
you everyone's using WeChat and then if
everyone is using the QR system for for
payments like we we chat pay right and
if they're using the QR system for
making contacts and everything it just
it's just like much more easy and
seamless to just come and it is so
basically I think the majority of
Chinese don't even have cash with them
whenever they go out they they don't
even have a purse or they don't bring
their cars they only have their phone
which is enough for paying everything so
no matter whether you want to go to a
restaurant or like convenience store
buying like oh you can go through this
process of like I'm scanning your QR
code and then transferring that money
directly to the business account so
which is very convenient and at the same
time it is sort of like PayPal so that
you can also transfer it to your friends
yeah and this yeah so are most people
using WeChat pay or Ali pay or a little
bit of both both I think everyone 50s a
split because you have to have a nolle
pay account - what for to pay for
Alibaba for yes and also for actually
they are like you can use both of them
to pay for every anything but like it is
more convenient to use like Ali pay when
you're like sort of shopping online they
can't like every everything you try now
you can bought it online so like no
matter you want a bamboo your house like
a dog a rabbit or anything you eat
something from America something from
Australia you can all buy them online so
yeah yeah yeah this is this is a new the
new era of like Amazon and Alibaba is
making us crazy
just two days sometimes even faster now
and very interesting and then now what
in terms of like you know being around a
lot of other young people your age
growing up in Shanghai there you know I
was also learning that you have a you
know by a certain age in China you or
your kind of like do you want to go into
this path or is it that's is it a
science or humanities or what is again
the distinction again the art versus
science or what is kind of like yes sort
of on one hand there's like literature
art and on the other hand there's like
all the science math engineering I'm
subject which is like within the
traditional Chinese system I don't think
any of the international school students
will take this path just because we have
such like different education system um
but when they are sitting in the like
traditional Chinese system they have to
decide this when they are entering like
sort of entering the house actually I'm
not very quite sure of this probably
during the sophomore of their high
school and then they all have to take
tests and also after that they'll have
to take the calc all which is sort of
like the SATs has for like for the whole
country it's called the goal call go cow
yes okay interesting and that's a
standardized test for both for either
science or art depending on where you
want to go or for both depending on
which where you want to go and then that
way you know kind of in your like
earlier high school hum which way you
want to go and then you would apply to
the next level of colleges or
universities with that okay so okay so
with your curiosity when you know when
you're young and you're getting all this
all these interesting of stimuli from
your parents and from your environment
and everything so you picked science and
art so how were you able to kind of like
go into the system when you were very
interested in both of them so yeah
I think one of the biggest problem
within the right now Chinese education
system which is probably also exists in
us like education system all over the
world is that people who think artists
are in science in science they sort of
keep these subjects separated and when I
say our it doesn't mean like only art
but like also philosophy and yeah all
that kind of literature area and also
like I don't think that people should
keep these subjects apart for example
when we are looking at the link between
philosophy and science lots of great
philosophers in the world actually
scientists themselves for example like
Aristotle and Plato they come up with
like some frameworks when look at
observing the world and also for example
Karl Popper she aqui he is sort of the
reason why right now we are falsifying a
null hypothesis when we are during
experiments and researchers and he is a
philosopher himself so I don't think
that people should keep like art - art
and science - science I think it is very
important to take an interdisciplinary
approach where you are solving a problem
because a problem for example when we
are classifying a problem - science
science problem it is not only science
problem it is it is a social problem
that it might matters a lot of people
around the world it is also like of lots
of few problems because both of them are
trying to understand the world better
and predict how it functions and yeah so
I think all problems within the world is
a complex system so all problems within
the system should not be separated alone
so that I don't think that in this case
the problem can be solved yeah I agree
with you that it's time to have science
and art be more interdisciplinary when
the children are learning it that's so
important especially since art kind of
helps us think outside the box it helps
us make designs that make science more
relatable for for the public as well
which is very important and and science
can help art because then science can
help art be competent
surely more about progressing
civilization in certain directions of
progress so now you did International
boarding school so you know what's that
like in middle school in high school for
you it was very fun from the star when I
was in Middle School and then I was
suddenly told that we need I need to go
go to a boarding school without my
parents and then to live with my friends
no first days like it was a bit
intimidating for me but then it turns
out very good because my parents are I
was like a very very independent child
when I was very little my parents were
super good with me doing my own stuff
and then like sort of like managing my
own time and not like sort of saying
that this is the score that you need to
get and like did you finish your
homework that kind of thing so I was
raised as a pretty intervention child so
it wasn't a great challenge for me to
like live alone with my friends and with
the teacher from the dorm so yeah it was
very fun now this is interesting you get
shipped to in middle school so you're
like you know you're what ten yeah
you're a ten or eleven years old and
then where's the International boys
school is it outside of Shanghai it is
within shy but it's like very far very
far like an hour or so drive - okay and
then you you start living with other ten
eleven twelve year olds you know like
kind of like a dorm system and then do
you go back to see the parents every
couple months no no every every weekend
in the weekend you will go back to
parents okay interesting okay so that's
not too bad I thought you know it can be
good you know five days without parents
you're building independence exactly I
love it like the island I love the
balance there because I do have time to
spend with my family but on the other
hand I can do like independent studying
and then hang out with my friends
yeah yeah that's so important I it's
very interesting thinking about what the
ideal model for education design is and
you know we talk and think a lot about
that like what would be the best code
for for kids to learn when they're
birthed into the world what could give
them the best big picture of what's
happening the complex systems
understanding of of our world now when
you're doing the International boarding
you went from middle to the high school
in the same international boarding
school okay and then in high school you
picked up like tons of these activities
did you do these also in middle school
yeah some of them are middle school yeah
this list is very long you did our
Arctic protection wildlife protection
editor the science journal which you
mentioned earlier to ice skating this is
all very cool yeah tell us about all
these skinny I started after primary
school and then like there's a period of
time that I was trying to like become
professional ice skater however I
decided not to I want to keep it as one
of my hobby so I came back and then I
started to like shift more and like
focus to my academic life but also I'm
trying to keep dad as well like because
I did learn a lot from ice skating so I
tried my best to keep that as one of my
hobbies while studying in like the
middle and high schools and for others
for the Arctic one and well f1 myself
was like very very environment whole
person so like I did care about my lives
and the environment a lot since I was
very little I would like yellow and my
parents because like they forgot to like
turn off the tab or like they with his
electricity in the house so all my
parents are like they know that so like
they are pretty supportive of that as
well and that is when I decide
I think it's in middle school so like I
decided to apply to a like Arctic
expedition so it starts with my let me
have some images - on the Arctic
expedition so it starts with my
interesting biology I want to see like
how is it to work with a bunch of
scientists like bananas and also also
like people from different fields
different countries and that was like a
very very very life-changing event just
because like I got in touch with people
all over the world it was pretty similar
with Minerva the community that people
come from all over the world and I was
like 14 or 15 at that time I guess 14
and it is that time I realized how it is
so deep so important to like meet people
from different culture and then to sort
of take their perspectives because we so
that we can like view a problem from
multiple perspectives and probably solve
it yeah like think outside the box think
outside your own mindset so that is very
life changing for me and also during
that trip I noticed how I am passionate
about like the interdisciplinary
approach because we have artists we
painted during the workshops we did some
of the researchers with scientists as
well and you just had a lot of fun yeah
we did we run into the Arctic Ocean it
was it was very fun and after a few
minutes we were told that a polar bear
polar bear is approaching so you need to
run we saw a lot of pull of your like 20
or something polar bears
yeah and during that expedition I also
obtained some perspective on education
there was was when one of the botanists
showed me like the oak tree the oak tree
we know are like very tall and like
large trees there but like the oak tree
in Arctic is like this little they're
like grass I was like this oh yeah
for like 20 years like this big white
exactly I was like is this okay yeah it
is and I was like what makes the
difference
why oak tree in cities are like much
taller and then oak trees here in arctic
are very very little roots can't go down
to get as much soil why not yeah that is
one of the explanation and then what he
said was like he lies on the ground and
he's like come on live you say I was
like why don't we I need to lie on the
ground but like I did well he told me
but at the moment when I lie down the
wind that was like howling through us
suddenly disappeared so he said this is
why that the oak trees are much closer
to the surface to the earth than what we
see in warmer places because they can
avoid wind they can survive for a longer
period of time the avoid like without
the wind they can like obtain the
transpiration rate to a slower rate so
that they don't lose water that often
and that is how a species adapt to
experiment and that is the moment where
I realized that I can actually learn
through like these kind of experience
more than sitting in the lecture room
and listen and like memorizing textbook
information and that kind of episode has
heaven a lot so I did learn a lot during
the that expedition and that is this
expedition is one of the reason why I
chose Minerva later on I love that love
that so it's so first you had to go
through a process of applying to get
into the Arctic expedition yes I was
actually the only students from China
that applied yeah it got they got it yes
how many people got into the expedition
trip I can't remember but like a hundred
the world very well and then that's all
around the age of like 14 15 year olds
is also some of the college college
types - yeah very interesting
and then so when and when you got into
that program like you said it was cool
both learning from different lenses
different people from different cultures
that's such an important way to kind of
bring bring civilization all together
and then to the other cool thing was
that when you saw things like the little
tiny oak tree you were again you were
able to see a new way of like wait why
is it like that kind learn more about
science and that can make art while
you're there you're making art with the
other ones so these things coming
together kind of led your interest into
Minerva as well so then tell us about
how you went from you know doing all
these leadership activities in your
school and then applying to Minerva so I
got to know Minerva from a current
Minerva students who is like now in
Hyderabad or Seoul Hyderabad I think and
so from the year before one year above
you one or two years some like friends
in Shanghai that you knew in Shanghai
that applied amazing network school that
is really cool at that time I was
looking at what school to put on my
college list because I am both applying
to the US universities and also UK
universities so I was wondering one day
and then suddenly like on mutual friends
a sort of linked us together and they
say she went to Minerva and I was like
this maneuver I never heard of this
school in my life and then that students
actually sat down with me and then go
through what is Minerva like how is her
experience here for like the whole
afternoon and that is the moment when I
realized like this is probably the
education that I want and that is the
most suitable for me and then from there
then this is great that you have a
mentor that had wondered
like an alumni or a current student that
was able to help teach you because that
is now you know we talk about that a lot
on the show this mentor to student is
it's a big deal bloom to Sigma is a huge
thing in education for children it puts
some two standard deviations above the
above the mean if they get that so
that's crucial and then you had a an
application process to go through to get
into Minerva Minerva acceptance rates
extremely low so you know so you were
you were really putting together kind of
your you know your big picture both
contribution that you've done in middle
and high school as well as you know what
your vision is so what kind of what was
like your vision that you were telling
them about that got you into it so like
I was I am really interested in
neuroscience and also from what I said
before I have really interested in you
know this very approach to it so
neuroscience philosophy and psychology
are the three subject that I am really
interested in because like I am so
curious about like how a bunch of
neurons like their cells and then how
can they make you think how what makes
the difference between person and person
like your brain is not like very
different from my brain but like we
think differently and we have different
perspectives and we are like such
different individuals so that is what I
was like really really curious about and
that is why from the field of science a
field of biology I decided to study like
neuroscience in the future and then
what's your what's your like favorite
part about you know you were just
describing a little bit about like it's
crazy that you know your mind grew up in
a different place got different stimuli
but we're you know brains are such
similar you know processing systems at
the same time what are you most excited
about neuroscience psychology like
within consciousness within kind of that
you know that framework you know what
are you what are you thinking about like
the most putting most of your time on
for me there are two areas one is like
understanding so understanding how brain
works how it functions under
from conditions and how if worms like
the personality of different people and
like the relationship between genes and
brains like nurture and nature and all
that kind of things so like
understanding what is going on within
our body and the other thing is mental
illness so I'm really interested in like
psychiatry psychology and what we can do
to use like the most cutting-edge tools
optogenetic tools were like other
methods like drugs to cure or like
Ellie's work on the like curing that
mental illness yeah love it love it this
is what I'm talking about nineteen year
olds that are they're super pumped about
helping with mental illness helping with
understanding our minds and like this is
what I'm talking about I love it love it
okay and then now now like you know
you're finding yourself you know part of
the Minerva ecosystem now you're a
freshman you know you're you know you
landed in San Francisco first you know
we have we have you know some images
about this too or you find yourself here
you're you're starting to also make some
you know some art and some of some of
your creations and then you know what
what would you say has been you know
this this like these these moments of
like whoa I'm in the u.s. I'm in San
Francisco you know I'm with a bunch of
other international students tell us
about this feeling this it feels amazing
so so I told you before that I went to
international schools like the the U as
kind of mindset and like the environment
isn't very unfamiliar for me however the
community is it is so interesting that
we have such a diverse community we have
like 150 students coming from more than
50 plus countries and it is so
interesting to get their perspective of
like what is going on in their country
and how for example how they view and
ideology that like differently for my so
that is one of the most
Thing Thing like in the Minerva
community and also I think nazar
mentioned before we have like 1000 ones
where a bunch of students pretend their
own country with like their food and
their culture norms I'll share with the
community and that is very very
interesting and also during classes so I
so during classes we don't we don't
lecture so Minerva classes doesn't
contain any lecturing all the studying
about this class we have to done it
before by your own so the ideology is
like if you can access these kind of
information online
why don't you do so like why don't you
lower yourself most of the current like
education like the higher education like
the universities they put money they put
time into lectures which students can
basically find them online so Minerva
ideology is like don't waste that time
during class we only apply what should
why yeah and also discuss the point so
yeah so the the the class is actually
very intense because the professors are
really pushing us to think hard and to
answer questions about for example how
how leadership how like different styles
of leadership can listed like different
regime shifts within the state stays
like a complex system perspective and
like how do you how to deal with the
unpredictability and non-linearity with
the system and for empirical analysis
which is like Natural Science in other
schools we look at how to mitigate bias
during researchers how different
research type for example observational
study interventional study case study
how these types can be suitable for
different like hypothesis and questions
that you want to solve so it's really
interesting to learn and apply these
kind of skills and to also like to use
them in real real world situation
there's a sort of
said that we do use use it in daily life
so it's really like it's amazing
experience you did this is very cool
that it's a it's a it's a you learn on
your own through the internet resources
that you have and you study on your own
and then you go in at class you only
discuss and apply
yeah and that's so cool and then so you
have a 15 or 18 you said in every
classes and then and then the the
teacher professor the way you're
interacting with them is that they what
did they do they ask you about the
material that you've that you've taken
in and that you talk to them and you
talk to the other students how does that
tell us professors can either ask
questions about the material that we buy
ourselves before the class and also we
have like breakouts so putting giving us
a different context like putting what we
learned abstract that skill and put it
into a context with because like you
have to react differently according to
you like the different context that you
are in like different situations so we
are going to put that into context and
say like from in this context I think
principled negotiation is better than
other kind of negotiation because we
need this is how we achieve our purpose
so that is how the like and after the
breakout ends will go to debrief where
each group share their own thoughts and
then I'm having a discussion about what
can we do better and like the
professor's will also ask some questions
about their work yeah and then you also
go out and do activities in the city and
Meszaros mentioning which is so cool as
well what were some of your you know
favorite the activities that you went
out in the city and you learned the
activities so like we have two parts of
interacting with the city the first one
is the LBA the location-based
assignments which pushes like for
students to go interact with the city
because there will be no difference if
you don't go out yeah the feeling's we
like we all take classes on compute
like through the internet so if we don't
use the resource of the city properly I
would like it would we would not benefit
you so one of the location based
assignments is like that is upcoming
actually it's like when we are learning
game theories inform onassis we have to
go and watch a game and then do like
where we learn apply what we learned
during class and to that game so and
then write a paper about it and also we
have I think nazar mentioned is utopia
and dystopia to like observe a location
for five hours and then see how people
interact with them and yeah that all
kind of sort of thing and we also have
like interview interview one of the like
a person from one organization in the
Bay Area and then to get a sense of like
analyze their leadership style their
organizational structure how can they do
better with the weakness the SWOT
analysis so yeah that is the kind of
that the part of location-based
assignment and on the other hand we have
civil partners civil partners are the
partners who will support us during our
final project the final project are all
the real world real world problems that
we want to solve for example I was with
nazar and our problem is like how to
increase the awareness of biotech
citizen science in the Bay Area because
like I said science is only science
about especially biotech like people
have this zero type that only science
scientists can do scientists however we
really want more diversity into the
field exactly one artists who want like
computer scientists do in this field and
then to actively solve a problem
together
that's the interdisciplinary take that
is so then after we choose the question
the big question that we're interested
in we're going to pair up with a civic
partner who is organization within the
Bay Area of whether a business and an
NGO or any kind of organization and then
together we'll be solving this problem
so the organization that cooperating
with us is power curious
and it is acting as like a biotech
hackerspace that is open for anyone so
yeah this is where we are working on and
the more you talk about the way the
nervous school is designed the more I
realize that this is a very ideal way
for yeah for students to become educated
especially the travel into different
cultures around the world and the local
assignments that you get and then the
discussion and application of all
everything that you're learning like I'm
just like so in love like with Minerva
Schools program well we you know we got
a you know we messaged Robin about this
too though where we want to do a greater
partnership with whatever school so well
you know I will include her in the in
the email later and and we hope to you
know to strike up something with you
guys on a larger scale because it's just
so exciting learning from you guys he
come here your 19 year from around the
world you're getting to hang out with
each other and just it's so beautiful it
is it's it's beautiful
okay so now you know you you were giving
us a an understanding of you know of
your science interests your art
interests we have a couple of your art
as well Ron we can pull those up you can
explain to us yeah so this is so what so
what's going on in your art oh I didn't
I didn't like study art I didn't study
art at all but when I was four all my
free time I love to like do dueling's I
love how the colors the combination of
all colors and also yeah photography as
well so I really really appreciate the
art in life and I think it is very
important to sense the like the details
that makes you that makes your life a
lot more happy so I think by like
looking at the art and within our lives
is like one way to like sort of making
your life better
yeah and then what are you specifically
looking for in that detail in art that
can make life better well for me it is
basically anything that there appreciate
for example when I was like looking
hello out when I was like wandering
around the San Francisco like city and
all the areas I'll be sort of having the
my putting all my photography
photographer mindset which allows me to
like to look at the details like the the
blue sky the ocean the clouds and also
like the street performers in pretty
much Alec details and I through
photography I really learned how to
appreciate for example a sunny day and
how to appreciate very detailed things
and that will literally make me very
very happy about it
so yeah I can't enjoy my letter my life
much better there art yeah that's a very
profound statement I can enjoy my life
much better through art yeah you know
having that additional discipline as
something that is on your tool belt of
knowledge is very very important okay
and now some thoughts for me before we
get to these last simulation questions
you know you find yourself in the this
generation you're you know you're 19 and
you know you're born in the year 2000
which is very crazy to us and so you
know what what do you what do you feel
happening you know you were born with
the technology in your pocket you know
and you really had it throughout your
entire adolescent years like what do you
see happening in your generation and
with the ideas that you have to solve
some of these biggest problems that we
have
I do think right now we have a lot more
tools that we can use to solve the big
problems we have more advanced
technology we have like more events
databases and also education as well and
with the development of like internet
and all the technologies we have no
matter in which area like no matter in
biology or chemistry or computer science
technology that I do think that we are
working towards solving the problem but
however we we need to keep in mind that
we don't cause us more problem through
the development of tools that we need to
solve the problem so exactly just like
the genetic editing twins that I said if
we can actually modify human genes that
is like a mind-blowing process that
maybe the world can become like like for
example the rich people can cure any
diseases like they are able both if they
are capable of doing anything they would
sort of like the superhuman I'm kind of
species if I can say that and where the
pores have to do deal with all like the
diseases and all that kind of like the
separated world and I don't want
hopefully it did not I don't want
anything like look just like that we
cannot like pollute the environment more
through our process of like
industrialization where like developing
new technologies we really need to keep
be aware of what are the consequences
long-term rather rather than in the
short term so like we need to think what
will happen to these twins like 17 years
ago like yeah it's so like a long time
like like afterwards yeah the way you
speak about longitudinal studies on
humanity is again this is incredible
being you know 19 and thinking this way
is so so important and you know even the
visions that you have of what could go
wrong as well how do we prevent how do
we preventatively you know solve these
issues that could
rise alright let's let's do our round of
simulation questions at the end first
question is are we alone in the cosmos I
don't think so I don't think so just
because in terms of possibility I don't
think so because we don't first we still
don't know what there's the edge of the
universe and we don't know we we only
have like a limited amount of knowledge
about the cosmos the universe so I don't
believe that we can say that for sure we
are alone in the universe but however we
have like this great silence that we
haven't heard from any of other like
extraterrestrial intelligence like
living organisms so like it actually
makes me a bit sad because like whenever
we think that whenever I think that we
might be alone in the universe
but yeah I don't think that is like
statistically probable so I do believe
that there there are lives out there but
it is it just like depends on time that
how long that we are going to find them
and then this is simulation so yes you
have another we are searching for life
that is only similar to us so like we
are only searching for life that can
communicate with us that is really well
because like if we find another form of
life that we cannot communicate with
that would be a lot more different
however
like our knowledge is only limited to
our self for example we only have five
senses for maybe like six senses right
now that we only maybe like we cannot
imagine what we haven't experienced so
maybe there are lives like very close to
us where we don't know we don't consider
that as a form of life or we cannot
categorize it as life just because we
don't feel the same at them so I do
think if we like we need to view the
like the concept of living organism
maybe you know water
we're in order to search for life
outside of Earth yes yes exactly their
imagination like you said we expand our
imagination and that's that's a huge
huge part of being able to think of what
else could possibly be you know
simulation so we must ask you are we in
a simulation I said before like I wish
we are I wish we are because at first it
would be fun like it would be fun just
because everything we know might be
different and the other thing is if we
are in a simulation that means someone
can explain what is happening right now
to us and they can explain the source
code exactly they are like this this
superior being that may explain a lot of
like problems that questions that we
have no idea right now for example like
how life comes from and like what is
evolution and all that kind of questions
so if we are in the simulation and
someone did create all these kind of
systems I would love to hear from him or
heard that like what like what causes
all these kind of things happening yeah
communing with the creator of the
simulation that's a very interesting and
being able to learn from that I like
that I like that answer a lot and then
running our own potentially as well
simulations last question what do you
think's the most beautiful thing in the
world
this is really hard but like in general
I think every every thing everything
your world is beautiful because it
exists for a purpose and you know like
you know all atoms and cells like they
come from Stardust and how that started
us can form us and how that start us I
mean the I mean the universe can for a
formula everything around us
that idea is very very amazing and also
just think about like in the bigger
scale that the earth and all the the
like the solar system and the
the Sun and how that coincidence makes
life possible and that is very beautiful
to me and also I have to mention
personally my border collie that you beg
your parents or 14 last again that's so
funny he's beautiful yeah yeah yeah it
makes me so happy knowing that we have
you know 19 year olds that are as smart
as you and that we have things like the
Minerva school for you guys to all get
together and keep working together on
solving some of these major challenges
that civilization is facing thank you
look shows thank you thank you thank you
thank you and it's you know even even as
something as interesting as as these as
these beautiful names that we have set
yes ash and Wong and that that you're
growing up with that and your English
name Alisha at the same time which is
you know I want um Chinese Ron needs a
Chinese name we we want our second names
to let us know your thoughts in the
comments below to what our second name
should be and check out Alicia's links
below as well going to support her
follow her or follow simulation follow
us thank you everyone for tuning and
give us your thoughts in the comments
below about what we were discussing we'd
love to hear from you share these
conversations out with other people as
well also support the artists and
entrepreneurs that you believe in
support them support us let's build the
future together huge shout out to Ronnie
Vargas thank you so much for producing
and directing we love you very much and
go and build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world
thank you and we will see you soon peace
[Music]
[Music]